so another set of polling that I want to
talk about today relates to it sort of
relates to the earlier poll I cited were
47% of Americans want Donald Trump
removed from office there's a new SSRS
poll that was conducted for CNN which
shows that special prosecutor Robert
molars approval rating is higher than
Donald Trump's in terms of their
handling of the Russia probe which is
both meaningless but also very important
so let's sort of break this down in
general when you compare the approval
rating of an elected official with a non
elected official it's not a hugely
relevant comparison right Melania has a
higher approval rating than Trump okay
well she's not an elected official she
does totally different things
first ladies commonly have higher
approval ratings than the president's
the reason that this matters even though
Robert Muller isn't a politician is that
the repercussions of Muller's
investigation depend on politicians what
Republicans have been trying to do is to
smear Robert Muller make Muller the
villain make him a make him out to be a
partisan hack even though his party is
the same as Trump's right it's the
Republican Party they're both
Republicans and the goal of this smear
campaign has been that if Trump fires
Muller maybe people won't really care if
people don't really think that Robert
Moeller is doing the right thing or
carrying out an unbiased investigation
if Mulder comes back at the end of this
entire thing and presents brutal
findings about what Trump and his
cronies did it's safer for Republicans
to do nothing about it if the public has
been turned against Robert Muller and
that's why it matters despite the smear
campaigns and the concerted effort to
discredit Moeller and his entire
investigation it matters that Moeller
still has a higher approval rating than
Donald Trump if this is the case
hopefully maybe possibly is a better
word to apply to it maybe there will be
pressure
unelected officials if it's still
Republicans who are empower when we get
molars findings maybe there will be
pressure on them to act instead of
ignoring them in part because Robert
Muller is just a partisan whose findings
don't matter when you look at the
numbers as I mentioned in the case
earlier today it's kind of depressing
right like the number of people
approving of Muller's handling of the
investigation should be way higher and
the numbers approving of Donald Trump's
handling of the investigation should be
way lower Trump obstructed the
investigation is trying to get it ended
early has fired people including FBI
director James Comey to try to get in
the way of that investigation
Trump's actions regarding the
investigation may be criminal and yet
people only approve of Muller's handling
of that investigation by a marginally
larger amount than they do of President
Trump's this is part of the crisis that
we're dealing with and use whatever word
you want write deplorable whatever word
you want to apply here I don't care what
word you use it is an embarrassment
internationally and I've been speaking
over the last three weeks I've spoken to
people in Denmark about what's going on
with Trump Finland about what's going on
with Trump Estonia a lot of people as
part of their digital democracy projects
and also in France about what's going on
with Trump I tell you this only because
I think it's interesting the trumpets
are emboldened by hearing that people in
Europe think that Trump's a disaster the
world is stunningly confused about not
only what is going on in the United
States but also why it hasn't been
stopped and I've had some interesting
conversations with people to make make
it an understated point two very
interesting sets of data and it is a
very good thing that the smear campaign
against robert muller at least it hasn't
worked well i think is fair to say
today's program sponsored in part by
Blink is calm slash Pakman I've talked
about blinkers before it's this awesome
app that I've been using for several
months now
what it does is take the best and most
critically acclaimed non-fiction books
and condenses them into 15-minute
audiobooks that you can listen to in one
sitting you could listen to ten books in
an afternoon I know that many in our
audience want to expand their horizons
and learn more about all sorts of
different topics but we're mostly
limited by time to some degree I know
I'm not able to read all of the books
that I want simply because I've got
other stuff going on and that's why
blink is - such a great tool you can
absorb the most important information
and insights from the book in one
sitting and our audience can get a seven
day free trial by going to blink accom
slash Pakman if you're watching on
youtube click the link in the video
description and after that free trial if
you like blinka stand i think you are
going to like it
you can continue enjoying thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about five
bucks a month go to be li NK is t.com
slash PA k ma n